das ist zdf heute live ganz herzlich
willkommen an diesem abend wer wird der
nächste us präsident das können wir auch
jetzt immer noch nicht sagen denn es
wird ist ein wirklich enges höschen
dieses an dieser kampf ums weiße haus
zwischen joe biden und donald trump das
kann man nicht anders sagen
in sechs bundesstaaten warten wir noch
auf die ergebnisse
donald trump hat getwitterte in
großbuchstaben stop the count also
stoppt die auszählung wie die lage in
amerika ist darauf blicken wir heute
abend wie immer freuen wir uns über ihre
und eure fragen und kommentare über die
kommentarspalten
und wenn ihr und sie uns über die zdf
heute app nutzt dann bitte alles an
diese adresse
ich freue mich dass heute abend im
studio ist die politikwissenschaftlerin
catrin kathrin entschuldigung ganz
clever es schön dass sie da sind
frau klug wenn sie sich die aktuellen
zahlen angucken würden sie eine prognose
wagen doch ich glaube jetzt sind wir
fast so weit es ist in vielen staaten
zum beispiel an der ostküste jetzt so
eng haben sie es schon gesagt aber es
zeichnen sich doch trends ab dass ein
weg ins weisse haus für joe biden
durchaus einfacher ist als für donald
trump also herr trump das haben wir
natürlich gleich in dem an dem wahlabend
noch gesehen
strengt jetzt den weg durch die
gesetzesebene und die also die gerichte
ebene vielmehr durch die instanzen an
aber vieles ist eben in vielerlei
hinsicht auch schon entschieden denn
seit märz gibt es 400 gerichtsverfahren
um viele kosmetische und detaillierte
teile dieser wahl in diesem hyper für
die realisierten system das heißt es
gibt gar nicht so so viele ansatzpunkte
wo er dann noch klagen kann er wird es
überall versuchen denn das ist
vielleicht auch sein gutes recht es ist
knapp aber wenn wir uns die margen
angucken in den bundesstaaten um den es
geht
die es jetzt geht sieht es doch für joe
biden besser aus und der weg ins weiße
haus ist ein einfacherer dann schauen
wir uns diese zahlen mal ganz konkret an
sebastian eben hat das zusammengestellt
wie der aktuelle stand
dinge ist tag zwei nach der us-wahl und
nach wie vor gibt es kein ergebnis nach
wie vor konzentriert sich das rennen auf
wenige schlüsselstaaten im moment der
donald trump bei 214 wahlleuten
herausforderer joe biden bei 253 in
nevada wurden gerade neue zahlen bekannt
gegeben
joe biden führt hier jetzt mit 0,9
prozentpunkten vor donald trump das sind
circa 11.000 stimmen extrem eng und
vermutlich der nächste start in dem man
ergebnis feststeht georgia rang liegt
hier bei 49 5 prozent beiden kommt auf
49,20 50.000 stimmen müssen noch
ausgezählt werden
pennsylvania hier holt joe biden weiter
auf 92 prozent sind ausgezählt und
donald trump führt knapp mit 1,8
prozentpunkten doch zehntausende wohl
mehrheitlich demokratische
briefwahlstimmen müssen noch gezählt
werden amerika wartet weiter gespannt
auf die ergebnisse aus den vier staaten
die die präsidentschaft entscheiden
werden nevada arizona georgia und
pennsylvania geht der trend so weiter
hat beiden gute chancen den wahlsieg für
sich zu entscheiden
[Musik]
entgegenfiebert alissa jung ist in
washington und jan fritsch ist in
phoenix in arizona und ganz kurz zur
erklärung der eine mit maske die andere
ohne denn beim 1
viele menschen drumherum man kann den
abstand nicht einhalten und bei
elisabeth washington ist rundherum lehre
so dass man dort keine maske tragen muss
dass nur zur erklärung alisa in
washington auf einer skala von eins bis
zehn wie hoch ist die nervosität in
diesem jahr richtig dass hier in
washington vor dem haus das ist doch
relativ ruhig also jemand jetzt keine
größeren proteste sind weit sind nur
menschen menschen vor ort aber nervös
sind hier natürlich trotzdem halle
ich glaube die allermeisten wird von
aufnahmen wie vor noch wirklich gebannt
vor bildschirmen und starten in welcher
screens weil wir warten auf dieses
ergebnis und wir haben es im beitrag
gerade gehört es ist wahnsinnig eng in
vielen bundesstaaten und es ist
tatsächlich noch alles offen als es
können immer noch keine entweder
präsident werden oder bleiben es ist
wirklich in zu diesem zeitpunkt noch
alles möglich nun hat donald trump heute
auch getwittert unter anderem und von
legalen und illegalen stimmen gesprochen
und wir haben ja auch gerade schon kurz
angesprochen dass er die juristische
auseinandersetzung suchen wird und auch
in einzelnen staaten schon gesucht hat
wie ordnen sie das ein
es ist ganz wichtig er hat sich heute
also schon mehrfach per twitter zu wort
gemeldet gemeldet und so gut wie jeder
tweet wurde auch schon wieder von
twitter markiert weil er eben
irreführend sein könnten bezug auf die
wahl weil das was donald trump da macht
oder was er jetzt schon wieder tut ich
hab mir einen tritt in den wir auch
gerne mal kurz besprechen können also er
spricht davon dass im prinzip alle
staaten die jetzt in richtung beiden
tendieren die möchte er eben gerichtlich
angehen und da spricht er dann also von
wahlfälschung und sagt dafür gibt es
sehr sehr viele beweise
diese beweise gibt es eben nicht das ist
der punkt bzw hat sich noch nicht
vorgelegt und es ist ja auch sehr
interessant
nur in den staaten wo beiden und die
demokraten vorne liegen sagten dass er
richtig geprüft werden das heißt ja im
umkehrschluss die staaten in denen er
vorne liegt da ist dann alles okay und
da muss man sich natürlich schon fragen
das ist ja schon auch ein bisschen
merkwürdig und es ist natürlich am ende
auf die frage wie weit kommt er denn
überhaupt mit solchen klagen weil dafür
müssen eben beweise vorgelegt werden
ich möchte an dieser stelle gerne einen
kommentar eines users einen einbauen wie
gesagt es ist ein kommentar eines users
zitat von peter p über facebook
der typ mit der locke benimmt sich wie
ein kleines baby im kaufhaus stampft mit
den füßen weil er seinen willen nicht
bekommt erbärmlich r kämpft mit allen
mitteln wird aber doch die wahl
verlieren gott sei dank wie gesagt ist
nur 1 kommentar den wir hier weiter
geben was wann rechnen sie denn damit
dass es tatsächlich ein ergebnisse
ergeben wird noch ein bisschen schwierig
zu sagen wobei jetzt tatsächlich heute
die nächsten stunden und morgen die
nächsten stunden entscheidend sein
könnten weil in pennsylvania
beispielsweise als ein bundesstaat mit
besonders vielen wahlleuten dieser zu
holen gilt nämlich 20 stücken gibt allen
jetzt also im rekord wie die anderen
bundesstaaten auch die zellen daraus
teilweise wirklich zeitnah und die
rechnen tatsächlich also schon bis
morgen auch wieder noch mit weiteren
ergebnissen das heißt wir könnten also
schon ein bisschen schlauer sein und
auch in den anderen staaten ganz im
beitrag kurz gehört in georgia geht es
nur noch 50.000 stimmen auszuzählen also
wir rücken dem ganzen immer näher
die frage ist und bleibt wird sich das
ganze aber weiter verzögern
im falle von solchen klagen wie sie von
donald trump angestrebt werden vielen
dank an die sehr jung für den moment
nach washington und dann gehen wir
weiter nach arizona wo eine userin auf
youtube gerade fragt pp lopez arizona
wird auf manchen seiten schon als
komplett ausgezählt ausgewiesen jan
können sie dazu was sagen
jahres hängt aber davon ab wie man fragt
also es war schon noch in der wahlnacht
dass jeder eigentlich konservativen
sender fox news bekannt gegeben hat dass
arizona schon ausgezählt sei und an die
demokraten fallen würde was eigentlich
eine riesen sensation wäre für diesen
eigentlich sehr republikanischen sehr
religiösen staat hier
dann sind auch andere
nachrichtenorganisationen noch
nachgezogen associated press in den
nachrichten agentur hat sich auch
festgelegt dass der beiden und die
demokraten hier den start gewonnen haben
das sind aber noch nicht alle also große
nachrichtensender wie zb cnn und auch
andere wollen sich noch nicht festlegen
und sagen es ist im moment noch zu früh
jetzt schon die wahl hier in arizona
einer seite zuzuschlagen
nun sehen wir hinter ihnen anhänger
einer seite gerade jubeln das sind
offensichtlich jump anhänger wie ist
denn die stimmung dort und vielleicht
können sie ein bisschen zeigen und
erklären
die lage dort ist ja absolut es ist
jetzt gegen mittag hier in phoenix in
arizona ich kann es einmal zeigen
hinter uns sind also tramper anhänger
haben sich versammelt das sind etwa 30
menschen die hier zusammen gekommen sind
auch bewaffnet muss man sagen was sehr
befremdlich ist aus einer deutschen
perspektive das heißt es sind durchaus
menschen hier die haben ihre gewehre mit
gewalt also keine kleinen waffen sondern
durchaus rot gewehre langwaffen
maschinengewehre und das hat natürlich
immer etwas einschüchtern dass der
deutschen perspektive und das ist auch
nicht das erste mal heute dass die
menschen sich versammelt haben gestern
zum beispiel gleich um die ecke hier
also fünf minuten zu fuß etwa entfernt
ist das elexxion office wo die stimmen
ausgezählt werden und schon dort haben
sich gestern abend menschen versammelt
auch bewaffnet und dort eben protestiert
und gegen eine angebliche wahlfälschung
und gegen ein vergessen oder nicht
auszählen ihre stimmen protestiert wie
sehen sie das als bedrohlichen vorbild
von etwas was viele befürchtet haben
nämlich dass es tatsächlich
bürgerkriegsähnliche zustände gibt in
amerika oder was soll dieses
zurschaustellen der waffen in diesem zu
diesem zeitpunkt bezwecken
es ist zumindest eine deutliche
verschärfung hier was wir in den
vergangenen tagen erlebt haben das hat
im wahlkampf also noch vor der wahl
eigentlich relativ die stimmung war
relativ entspannt also menschen die den
demokraten oder den republikanern
zugeneigt sind die haben nebeneinander
wahlkampf gemacht haben auch miteinander
gesprochen und sich teilweise hier in
der hitze arizona das wasser zu gereicht
das heißt da war die stimmung eigentlich
noch relativ freundlich das hat sich
allerdings mittlerweile verschärft also
seit der wahl merkt man das eben
spätestens seit gestern abend die
stimmung deutlich angespannter wird und
wir haben von hier mit menschen
gesprochen die hier mit ihren waffen zu
den protesten gekommen sind und die
sagen uns es geht auch darum ein zeichen
zu setzen dass sie das recht in der
öffentlichkeit waffen zu tragen ihre
songs in tiefe republikanischer staat
hier ist das waffenrecht sehr sehr lax
dass sie dieses recht eben auch weiter
ausüben wollen dass das gewehr auch als
ein symbol dafür dass sie nicht ihre
freiheitsrechte beraubt werden sollen
vielen dank jan fritsche für diese
eindrücke aus phoenix arizona und vielen
dank auch noch mal nach washington an
dieser stelle und wir blicken insgesamt
auf die lage in diesem land britta jäger
fasst zusammen und fängt passenderweise
in phoenix in arizona nicht in phoenix
arizona in einem diner in phoenix
arizona liegen die nerven blank
noch ist unklar wer in dem bundesstaat
das rennen macht hier haben sie trump
gewählt und glauben wie der präsident
dass bei der wahl nicht alles mit
rechten dingen zugeht
ich mache mir sorgen bin aber weiter
optimistisch wir werden sehen
und wir wissen alle dass ein kämpfer wir
können hier nach gucken ob unsere stimme
gezählt worden ist und meine stimme ist
abgelehnt worden das ist das problem
darum denken wir dass den amerikanern
die wahl gestohlen wird eine ungültige
stimme vielleicht auch weil sie selbst
einen fehler gemacht hat in arizona wird
noch ausgezählt genauso wie in nevada in
den bundesstaaten liegt herausforderer
beiden knapp vorn
sollte er sie beide holen würde das für
den demokraten reichen um ins weiße haus
einzuziehen
mit der niederlage vor augen wütet trump
auf twitter stoppt die weitere
auszählung fordert er in großbuchstaben
seine anhänger wie hier in michigan tun
es ihm gleich fordern die wahlhelfer
wütend auf das zellen einzustellen
auch in georgia wird noch gezählt trump
liegt hier knapp vorn und offizielle
sehen sich genötigt ihre wahlhelfer in
schutz zu nehmen
sie denken an die stimme jeder person
hier und im ganzen land diese leute sind
nicht in wahlfälschung oder in waal
unterdrückung involviert in mehreren
teilen des landes protest der tramp fans
und der beiden anhänger auf der straße
entlädt sich spannung über die frage wer
hier in den nächsten jahren rechtmäßig
regieren darf so sie sehen die
diskussion hier im stücki rom das was in
amerika passiert ist in vollem gang und
es war übrigens doch phoenix arizona
frau klüver es druckt diese vorwürfe der
wahlfälschung die muss man ja erst mal
ernst nehmen wenn jemand sagt es gibt
eine demokratische wahl und ich habe da
bedenken
dann ist es jedermanns recht zu sagen da
müssen wir genauer hingucken können sie
das von uns aus ihrer sicht noch mal
einschätzen auch vor dem hintergrund
dessen was wir in dem beitrag gerade
gesehen also historisch gibt es
keinerlei begründungen solche ängste zu
haben
wir haben gesehen dass zwei wochen vor
der wahl auch noch mal die großen
leitfiguren der verschiedenen
amerikanischen sicherheits agenturen vor
die presse getreten sind und noch mal
gesagt haben es gibt überhaupt kein
anzeichen dafür dass sind einer weise
flächendeckende wahlbetrug gäbe oder
auch eingriff in die wahlen sie haben
wiederum gewarnt also das ist jetzt fbi
und das cyber ministerium haben gewarnt
es gibt eingriffe in die wahl von des
informationen soll er sich gut und
vermehren man sonne gut aufpassen
man solle gut checken ob man nicht doch
vielleicht irgendwelche
verschwörungstheorien anheim fallen aber
an der wahl selber gäbe es keinen
zweifel die sei sicher und gerecht und
wir müssen auch noch dazu sagen weil es
jetzt so interessant wird in den quasi
einzelnen aus zehn locations das seit 20
16 weil daher eben die angst war dass
russland gegebenenfalls durch eine cyber
heck oder durch verschiedene angriffe
von außen sich wirklich tief hat
einmischen können in die wahl
jedes jeder bundesstaat noch einmal
extrem nachgebessert hat am wahlsystem
und besonders
als auch in der vorwahl in iowa für die
demokraten schiefgegangen ist technisch
elektronisch sie erinnern sich
vielleicht da hat jeder wirklich noch
mal gut aufgeräumt das heißt wenn wir
jetzt die staatssekretäre sehen die vor
die kamera treten uns sagen und ihre
tiere bundesländer verteidigung um zu
sagen wir machen hier alles nach fug und
recht und ordnung dann ist das auch so
leben kann man glauben schenken und der
brennen center for justice ein sehr
renommierter think tank der seit jahren
solche vorwürfe des wahlbetrugs prüft
der hat für diese wahl auch gesagt 0,0 0
25 prozent ist etwa einschätzungs mäßig
das risiko dass an dieser wahl an sich
gefälscht wird also wir können das
ausschließen
was heißt das für die juristische
klagewelle die trump und sein team jetzt
quasi los treten welche erfolge welche
möglichkeiten hat er da also worauf es
hauptsächlich an kommen wird weil ihre
korrespondenten schon darauf hingewiesen
haben es geht darum wie knapp ist es und
welche ja welche gesetzgebung gibt es in
den einzelnen staaten noch mal wir
besprechen das schon die ganze zeit
diese hyper föderalisierung gut wir
haben hier auch ein föderales system
aber doch so im detail separat sind
unsere bundesländer nicht voneinander
irgendwann greift natürlich auch die
bundesregierung quasi oder das national
recht es ist gerade beim wahlrecht in
den usa nicht der fall wahlrecht an sich
also ein allgemeines gleiches freies
reviews hier kennt steht nicht in der
amerikanischen verfassung
das heißt es wird um margen gehen es
wird in wisconsin zb darum gehen ist die
marge also der unterschied der stimmen
größer als ein prozent denn dann könnte
man gegebenenfalls nach gesetzgebung in
wisconsin nachzählen lassen aber dass
die zb eben nicht so aus und wer
internet uns dass wisconsin so ein staat
ist wo vorher geklappt worden ist am
supreme court und wo ein konservativer
richter der von donald trump quasi in
amt und würden gehoben ist nämlich brett
kevin ein ähnlich politisch als argument
gemacht hat hoch bedenklich wie der
präsident als er dann gesagt hat nein
nein
in wisconsin müssen alle wahlzettel
ausgezählt werden die wirklich bis zum
dritten ankommen und danach darf nicht
weiter gezählt werden und
das system hat herr beiden da die nase
vorn also ich glaube nicht er wird in
bestimmten oder in einigen bundesländern
einfach nicht damit durchkommen weil die
marge so klein ist und es gibt dann
einen sohn zünglein an der waage wann
dann wirklich noch mal neu gezählt wurde
und sieht nicht so aus aber mit der
strategie überall durchkommt
ich möchte gerne eine frage oder einen
aufruf noch einen flechten von gan
zeichen 67 über youtube die amis sollten
mal endlich für ein besseres wahlsystem
auf die straßen gehen das würde dem land
guttun
was sagen sie dazu also als amerikanerin
die wahlberechtigt ist würde ich
natürlich sagen mein gott das ist längst
überfällig
man hat es in der vergangenheit schon
mehrfach probiert es ist keine neue idee
elizabeth warren die für die demokraten
in den vorwahlkampf gegangen ist und aus
dem bundesstaat land stammt aus dem in
dem ich jetzt wohne nämlich
massachusetts hat auch im vorwahlkampf
gesagt genau dass wir brauchen ein neues
wir brauchen ein faires wir brauchen
jetzt ausgeglichenes wahlsystem wenn
jetzt habe ich immer noch ein wahlsystem
was dazu führt dass ländliche gegenden
viel mehr macht haben als stätte der
süden immer noch mehr macht hat als der
norden
das scheint auch nicht mehr
kontemporären wenn man sich anguckt wie
die leute im ganzen land herum ziehen
aber wir wissen auch dass wir ein
zweiparteiensystem haben und das
natürlich ein zweiparteiensystem immer
mitmacht verbunden ist und dass die
macht dann eben nur auf zwei köpfe quasi
verteilt werden kann und wer ändert denn
schon gern ein system was im am schluss
vielleicht dann den nachtzuschlag gibt
also die einzig letzte wirklich
kohärente der letzten reform ansatz den
wir hatten
der liegt schon weit über 40 jahre
zurück nämlich aus dem jahr 68
und ich glaube durchkommen würden wir
nur mit einer reform des wahlgesetzes
wenn der senat sich auch noch blau
verfärbt das heißt wenn joe biden quasi
durchmarschieren könnte dann ginge das
vielleicht danach sieht es im moment
stand jetzt auch nicht auf nein der
senat ist hart umkämpft also es ist
wirklich zur zeit ein patt aber es sind
eben zwei senatssitze in georgia die
einen so genannten wandfarben müssen
also quasi noch mal gewählt wird nicht
weil es da irgend eine unregelmäßigkeit
gegeben hat man gar nicht sondern weil
die margen in dem einen rennen so eng
sind und auf der anderen seite weil es
da eine spezial wahl gab also da geht
alles mit rechten dingen zu aber da wird
im januar noch mal gewählt werden
dann könnte sich durch eine stimme auch
noch die senatsmehrheit verschieben aber
das ist noch ein bisschen hin
an dieser stelle möchte ich gerne max
heinrich zitieren aus youtube der danke
für diesen live stream liebes zdf-team
geschrieben hat und wir danken an dieser
stelle für diesen positiven kommentar
vielen dank fürs zuschauen
das eine ist dass die juristische den
jurist der die juristischen spielraum
das andere ist ja der politische und
jetzt hab ich was gelesen was mich sehr
gewundert hat nämlich das ist die
verfassung den mitgliedern des wahl-
kollegiums keineswegs vorschreibt
entsprechend des wahlausgangs in ihrem
bundesland abzustimmen und ich habe
eigentlich in geschichte ganz gut
aufgepasst und in politischer
sozialkunde
aber das war mir neu und dann stellt
sich ja die frage was bringt denn dieses
wahlmänner kollegium überhaupt wenn sie
am ende überhaupt nicht gebunden sind an
das woran man sie gebunden glaubt ja es
gibt einerseits die gesetze und dann
gibt es die normen und man müsste sich
vielleicht richtigerweise sorgen machen
denn wie wir hauptsächlich gesehen haben
den letzten vier jahren sind die
politischen normen aus dem
amerikanischen system raus geblutet und
insofern ist vielleicht jetzt eine sorge
oder rum wie sich dann die wahlmänner
oder wahlfrauen verhalten berechtigt
aber historisch haben wir gesehen dass
es nicht der fall ist ist es gibt ein
paar bundesstaaten nevada und mehr
da dürfen sogar die wahlmänner und
-frauen die stimme splitten also da kann
es unterschiedliche
parteizugehörigkeiten geben da zählt
eben nicht dieses berühmte winner takes
all modell aber es gab natürlich das
nennt man die sogenannten faces elektras
die gab es in der vergangenheit auch bei
der letzten wahl 2016 aber in der regel
machen die nichts aus also die sind sind
da nicht so viele
das ist was ausmachen würde der grund
warum man jetzt darauf guckt ist weil es
natürlich sein werden dass joe biden
genau auf 270 kommt und es dann doch
vielleicht ein zünglein an der waage
sein könnte aber da gibt's dann
verschiedene spielereien in der
verfassung wo man quasi dann noch mal
nachhaken könnte es ein bisschen
kompliziert aber insgesamt hat die
historie nicht bewiesen dass das in
irgendeiner weise wirklich
ausschlaggebend werden könnte was halten
sie für unwahrscheinlich
ich halte es auch für sehr
unterschiedliche harry klein fragt über
youtube in diesem zusammenhang es wäre
schön zu wissen in welchen staaten die
wahl länder vom gesetz her strafen zu
befürchten haben wenn sie fremd wählen
das ist das was sie gerade die haben sie
immer die sind nicht super super hoch
aber es gibt sie ja also sie sind sie
pendeln in den bundesstaaten irgendwie
zwischen 500 ein paar tausend dollar
die gibt es und das haben manche in kauf
genommen aber in der regel noch mal wir
sind in einer sehr volatilen situation
was würde das einem einzelnen wahlmann
einer einzelnen wahlfrau bringen außer
groll und hass wenn man so möchte denn
es muss doch darum gehen jetzt relativ
schnell zu einer klaren entscheidung
kommen zu können
einerseits um das land wieder zu
beruhigen und zweiten sich dann mit der
nächsten großen aufgabe zu befassen
nämlich das land irgendwie wieder zu
einen und das hat die beiden ja auch in
seinen kommentaren heute nochmal gesagt
er möchte der präsident aller amerikaner
sein wie wäre nicht miteinander
verfeindet man müsse da sehr aufpassen
also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
ein oder zwei wahlmänner quasi über ihre
verantwortung hinaus noch zivilen
zivilen ungehorsam leisten würden um das
land nicht zur ruhe kommen zu lassen das
erscheint mir doch etwas abwegig weil
sie die beiden gerade angesprochen haben
wenn er seinen vorsprung weiter ausbauen
könnte und wenn alle juristischen
versuche des tramp lagers scheitern dann
wäre joe biden der nächste präsident der
vereinigten staaten was wäre von ihm zu
erwarten
innenpolitisch steht eben ein großes
stück arbeit bevor
wir ziehen gleichzeitig zu dieser wahl
bilanz über das corona management dieses
präsidenten wir haben gesehen dass die
demokraten hauptsächlich wirklich auch
an die wahlurne gekommen sind weil sie
sich diese verheerenden zahlen in den
usa angucken die demokraten verbinden
ganz klar die korona pandemie 100.000
neue fälle haben wir seit seit gestern
pro tag
die sterberate geht rapide in die höhe
auch in den bundesstaaten um die es
jetzt geht das hält das
gesundheitssystem in wisconsin ist kurz
vorm erliegen utah ist extrem schwierig
machen gerade die gleichen
entscheidungen wie damals in italien
nämlich wer wird hier noch versorgt
werden also das heißt erst mal muss er
sich mit der partie
die beschäftigen dann muss er sich mit
der wirtschaft beschäftigen das geht
quasi hand in hand aber er wird glaube
ich auch relativ schnell sich mit seiner
eigenen partei auseinandersetzen müssen
die ihm jetzt den rücken gestärkt hat
aber wir wissen sehr dass joe biden ein
kompromisskandidat war für die partei
und da werden jetzt die verschiedenen
flügel der partei ihn treten in die
gänge zu kommen was gerade klimapolitik
angeht wir haben gesehen
die amerikaner sind gerade aus dem
pariser klimaabkommen wirklich formel
rausgeflogen
und das wäre dann so eine erste
internationale amtshandlung die wichtig
wäre nicht nur weil der linke flügel das
will sondern weil die beiden das auch
sehr stark möchte und dann will er
natürlich und das hat er von vornherein
gesagt er will das transatlantische
bündnis kitten
und er will sich große mühe geben dass
wir uns quasi wieder verstehen über den
atlantik zu fall zur außenpolitik
wir versuchen mal einen blick zu werfen
auf die auf die karte wie sie im moment
aussieht und wir sehen hier sehr viele
rote bundesstaaten wir sehen sehr viele
blaue bundesstaaten und wir sehen sechs
die sind noch nicht ausgezählt als
alaska dabei das ist aber jetzt keiner
von denen auf die man so besonders guckt
aber wir schauen zum beispiel mal auf
nevada
da sind 89 prozent der stimmen
ausgezählt und wir sehen 48,5 liegen bei
trump und 49,4 liegen bei beiden nevada
könnte einer der nächsten staaten seien
georgia ist auch schon fast kult
vorausgezahlt zu sein die entscheidend
sind
nevada würde aber nicht reichen das sind
nicht genügend war das sind sechs
wahlmänner gedacht das würde noch nicht
reichen also das rennen bleibt sehr sehr
eng
patrick neuhold schreiben fragt zum
beispiel wie viele millionen haben die
demokraten schon für den prozess nach
der wahl gespart denn das kostet ja auch
ja immense summen wenn man nachzählen
lassen möchte oder irgendwie da noch mal
nachschauen lassen wir jetzt schön wenn
man sich von beiden parteien ständig
post schicken lässt denn ich weiß dass
zb beiden jetzt gerade für den nahkampf
noch mal sammelt sie habe mich heute
gerade dazu aufgefordert ich solle doch
noch mal 12 dollar spenden
denn dieser wahlkampf von joe biden hat
sich eben auch sehr viel mit
kleinstspenden finanziert werden
die demokraten haben weit weit weit mehr
geld eingenommen in diesem wahlkampf als
donald trump und zum beispiel den us
konzern müsste das nachzählen wenn ist
nämlich über der als unter der marge
liegt wo der staat nach sehen würde
müsste das ein kandidat selber bezahlen
und das würde einen dort ramp in dem
fall stark zu stehen kommt und der hat
sowieso schon an seiner wahlkampfkasse
ordentlich verloren und musste am
schluss ganz schön ordentlich sparen
also beiden ist auf jeden fall
finanziell besser aufgestellt in diesem
teuersten wahlkampf aller zeiten hohe 14
milliarde dollar hat dieser wahlkampf
gekostet zum vergleich die spd hat es in
der bundestagswahl auch mit 24 einhalb
millionen geschafft ihr sich wieder als
partner in diese bundesregierung wählen
zu lassen
also das sind die verhältnisse über die
wir reden aber joe biden hat auch wenn
er meine zwölf dollar noch haben möchte
eigentlich ein ziemlich dickes wie man
sagt watch ist okay dann schauen wir mal
auf die frage wer warum wien gewählt hat
ich hoffe ich spreche das richtig
auspowern melik cut mehr schreibt über
e-mail und auf verschiedenen anderen
kanälen joe biden hat so viele stimmen
wie kein anderer
präsidentschaftskandidat kann es sein
dass diesmal der dass dies diesmal der
fall ist weil die menschen nicht einen
kandidaten gewählt haben sondern mehr
eine abwendung der anderen politischen
seite also dass sie quasi beiden gewählt
haben einfach deshalb weil er nicht
donald trump ist ja ich glaube zum teil
und das hat mir auch in den umfragen
vorhergesehen 56 prozent der amerikaner
haben gesagt wir wählen den anti trump
und es gab ein schönes
kampagnen schild vorher nie functioning
adronit juni also irgendjemand irgend
ein erwachsener der ist könnte den
würden wir wählen oder vielleicht auch
eine zimmerpflanze aber nur nicht trump
und das war natürlich war es ich glaube
aber für seine anhänger hat beiden ein
wirklich auch ein robustes programm auf
den auf den boden gestellt also das hat
ja schon gut gemacht so dass ich glaube
ich dass gemischt hat zwischen den
menschen die gesagt haben nein nein wir
müssen uns und der welt auch noch mal
nachhaltig beweisen dass wir das nicht
sind wir sind nicht dieses hässliche
amerika wir sind nicht das land was zu
schuldzuweisungen in den ganzen globus
verteilt was sich zurückzieht volle
internationalen verantwortung und
verschwörungstheorien in die welt setzt
und das demokratische system auseinander
nimmt das sind wir nicht das war so eine
gruppe und ganz klar die andere gruppe
die hat auch wirklich gesagt nein
hier hat ein präsidentschaftskandidat
auch eine politik und ein programm mit
hand und fuß dass das land dann
vielleicht auch wieder auf die richtigen
beine stellen kann also es ist
vielleicht eine misch analyse aber ganz
klar ist und davon hat sich ja haben
sich die demokraten eigentlich die
richtig große blaue welle erhofft von
der anti tram wahl und das ist dann
nicht ganz so gekommen deswegen sind wir
hier am reden aber es waren doch viele
dabei die gesagt haben bis hierhin und
nicht weiter genau aber diese blaue
welle ist ausgeblieben und es gibt
offenbar immer noch sehr viele trump
fehler die auch trump wieder gewählt
haben und wenn man sich die
wahlbeteiligung angucke ihr eine
rekordhöhe 160 millionen wählern glaube
ich dann muss man davon ausgehen dass er
eigentlich nochmal wählerstimmen dazu
bekommen hat ja auch hat er etwas hat
die leute bewogen donald trump zu wählen
das ganz interessantes ist sich nochmal
die umfrage an zu gucken was ist was ist
das was ist das motivierende am
wahlprogramm quasi und sieht schon
fehler haben alle gesagt die wirtschaft
also was das dann zeigt ist das zum
beispiel amerika wirklich jetzt
gespaltene ist auch in der
informationsarchitektur im land ja also
amerikaner neben ganz andere wahrheiten
für sich war und auf fox news und selbst
vom präsidenten selbst ist immer wieder
die botschaft gekommen ich bin eher der
wirtschaft kann und er hat ein
hat ein großes plus gemanagt für für die
wirtschaft wir hatten bevor die pandemie
kam eine wirklich eine historisch
niedrige arbeitslosenzahl damit konnte
er auch ganz gut punkten das waren
fakten und andere fakten hat er sich so
zurecht gestreckt dass die leute
geglaubt haben die wirtschaft ist
wirklich das allerwichtigste
umgekehrt haben die an alte die andere
medien wahrgenommen haben sehr wohl
gesehen dass die korona krise ganz klar
mit einer sich erholenden wirtschaft
zusammenhängt so wie wir das auch in
deutschland eigentlich alle durch die
bank sehen und haben gesagt nein erst
sich auf die korona krise konzentrieren
und das war eben der hauptpunkt den joe
biden in den letzten wochen immer wieder
gesagt hat wir müssen uns erst wirklich
gesundheitlich erholen das in den griff
kriegen
und so haben wir in den umfragen auch
gesehen für wen war was wichtiger und
die wirtschaftsfragen haben die leute
die trump fehler wirklich bewegt und für
ihn sind sie wegen dieser idee in die
bresche gesprungen kurz bevor wir hier
den sack zu machen möchte ich gerne mit
ihnen gemeinsam nochmal joe biden hören
der sich geäußert hat und wir haben
schon darüber gesprochen dass er gesagt
hat ich möchte ein präsident für alle
amerikaner sein und dieses land einen
und das haben wir uns nochmal an
ich habe wahlkampf gemacht als demokrat
aber ich werde als amerikanischer
präsident regieren
der präsident selbst ist keine partei
institution er repräsentiert alle und
das beinhaltet die pflicht sich um alle
amerikaner zu kümmern
das ist exakt das was ich tun werde ich
werde genauso hart für die arbeiten die
mich nicht gewählt haben wie für jene
die mich gewählt haben
das wird harte arbeit haben sie schon
gesagt glauben sie es wird ihm gelingen
dieses sehr gespaltene zerrissene land
denn das zeigen diese wahlergebnisse ja
auch dass es ihm gelingen wird es zu
einem es wird ein unglaublicher kraftakt
aber ich glaube das wichtigste ist jetzt
dass eine demokratische partei selbst
wenn sie dann die wahl gewinnt wenn joe
biden die wahl annimmt was er tun wird
als präsident zuhört und zwar weiter ins
land geht sich gesprächsbereit zeigt
ich glaube dieser riss geht zum beispiel
genau durch die arbeitende bevölkerung
in amerika die sich nie wirklich erholt
hat von den schweren auswirkungen der
finanzkrise 2008 die gesehen hat wie ihn
der amerikanische traum wie sand durch
die finger läuft früher hat man immer
gesagt eigenes auto eigenes haus
natürlich ist das amerikanische system
wird viel auf pump finanziert das brach
alles weg in der finanzkrise 2008 das
land ist steht vor schweren
herausforderung 50.000 menschen sind
jetzt wieder der opioid krise zum opfer
geworden
einer von vier amerikanern bekennt sich
dazu nahrungs arm zu sein in einer aus
20 amerikanische familien hungert jemand
ist gibt ganz ganz schwere umstände mit
denen sich amerika jetzt
auseinandersetzen muss und gerade die
sogenannten working poor die weißen die
weiße bevölkerung die jetzt unter 40.000
dollar im teil zum jahr verdient denen
die sind verärgert und für die war
donald trump der kandidat der gesagt hat
nein dass ihr müsst das sie so nicht auf
euch nehmen dass die eliten euch immer
unterbuttern ich bin ein kämpfer ich bin
euer ich bin der ja ich bin der anti
eliten mensch passt nicht so ganz
wirklich zu seiner biografie aber
whatever
und da muss joe biden jetzt sein da muss
er gut zuhören können und da muss es
verstehen was den leuten wirklich unter
den nägeln brennt und er muss zum
beispiel eben auch sein steuerpaket
jetzt durch bekommen dass
steuererleichterungen in den händen der
amerikaner landon denn das haben sie
jetzt immer gerade die champagner immer
jump das zünglein an der waage gegeben
dass nur er dafür sorgen kann dass sie
am ende des tages mehr geld in der
tasche haben
und da das wird ein ganz großer
programmpunkt werden für dubai die leute
müssen spüren dass es ihnen unter joe
biden besser gehen wird
und weil ich gerade höre dass wie sie
die beiden nur ganz kurz gesehen haben
und danach ein technisches problem
aufgetreten ist und wir ihnen joe biden
aber nicht vorenthalten wollen nicht nur
was er zu sagen hat sondern auch wie ihr
dabei aussieht zeigen was ihnen einfach
noch mal
ich habe wahlkampf gemacht als demokrat
aber ich werde als amerikanischer
präsident regieren
der präsident selbst ist keine partei
institution
er repräsentiert alle und das beinhaltet
die pflicht sich um alle amerikaner zu
kümmern
das ist exakt das was ich tun werde ich
werde genauso hart für die arbeiten die
mich nicht gewählt haben wie für jene
die mich gewählt haben
es wird keine blauen oder roten staaten
mehr geben denn wir gewinnen nur die
vereinigten staaten von amerika tja wenn
man sich das an guckt frau tesch druck
und sich den kommentar von unplugged
einem user auf youtube durchliest der
schreibt wind trump nicht gewinnt wird
es in den nächsten monaten bürgerkriege
geben
wie groß ist ihre sorge davor dass das
stattfindet vielleicht ist bürgerkrieg
an etwas zu großes wort aber wie groß
ist ihre sorge tatsächlich vor unruhen
auf den straßen die bilder aus phoenix
haben wir ja vorhin schon gesehen also
bürgerkrieg nein auf gar keinen fall
wird nicht passieren
wie er ich habe vor der wahl immer
gesagt ja ich kann mir schon vorstellen
dass es vereinzelt noch zu gewalt kommt
also nicht nur wie in arizona wo sie
open carry haben ist kurz vor der wahl
auch einer einer klage stattgegeben
worden dass auch die so genannten
michigan da also die einwohner von
michigan mit einer schusswaffe ins
wahllokal kommen können das wollte die
staatssekretärin auf gar keinen fall
denn sie wollte nicht dass irgendjemand
an seiner freien wahl behindert wird
oder eingeschüchtert wird dadurch dass
jemand mit einem riesen gewehr da steht
aber das hat sie nicht wieder
hinbekommen das heißt es standen leute
mit gewehren daumens ist trotzdem nichts
passiert ist die letzten paar tagen ist
sehr ruhig geblieben
eine gewalt strategie die stand auch für
donald trump auf dem zettel da wäre
nämlich die möglichkeit gewesen wenn
jetzt wirklich über die nächsten tage
und das versucht er natürlich über
tweets street seiner familie noch ein
bisschen anzustacheln das gefühl auf der
straße denn eine version die sich quasi
ins weiße haus zu bugsieren wäre für
gross krawalle auf den straßen zu sorgen
und dann unter dem land order duktus zu
sagen nein
um den frieden im land zu behalten
müssen wir jetzt aufhören mit den
auszählungen müssen die legislativen in
den einzelnen bundesstaaten und da gibt
es viele die eben in republikanischer
hand sind die müssen die wahlmänner
stellen das wäre doch dann sehr
undemokratisch aber da hätte er
gegebenenfalls die möglichkeit und das
wäre dann doch ein sehr verquerer einem
sehr verquere art und weise ins weiße
haus zu kommen aber das zumindest hatte
er auf dem strategie zettel
ich glaube das wird nicht aufgehen denn
wir sehen jetzt das land ist großteils
friedlich geblieben oder ist komplett
friedlich geblieben und ich denke es
wird auch so weiter gehen das traue ich
meinen amerikanern zu vielen dank
kathrin klug dass sie bei uns im studio
waren vielen dank für diese einschätzung
und wir halten sie natürlich auf dem
laufenden
und wenn es denn irgendwann ein ergebnis
dieser us präsidentschaftswahl gibt dann
erfahren sie das ganz natürlich hier bei
uns im zdf ich wünsche ihnen noch einen
schönen abend danke fürs zuschauen
[Musik]